**Very Nice Claps**
Movie reviews
I'm sorry, ok I'm not plann... I wasn't
planning to make more.. *ALIEN VOICE* BUT HAVE YOU WATCHED THE NEW STAR WARS!?
OH MY GOD! I'M THE BIGGEST STAR WARS FAN EVER!!!!! (i get it dude)
*NORMAL VOICE* Im not that really big of a star wars fan
Um.. * think about life choices*
Seeing all the following all the following and excitement for this latest film,
I was actually pretty excited about seeing it as well.
But while watching the film I find myself just.. Not enjoying it. (YEA IT TERRIBLE)
I thought it was...
Really bad *light chuckle* (Yep)
But then..
I go
*GETS A SEIZURE*
......
FELIX!
This is Star Wars!
Everyone loves star wars! (with emphasis.)
Stop being such a cynic and enjoy the film! * pewdipie inside feud*
So...
I keep watching.. but then, out of nowhere,
comes a joke so bad that it makes your whole face just..
*ALIEN FACE* turn inside out
*GETS A SEIZURE AGAIN
NO FELIX!
This is Star Wars!
It's got... 94% on Rotten Tomatoes! ( I read that someone hacked and changed the tomatometer)
If you don't like this movie.. then yo- there's something wrong with you! * super serious Pewdipie*
Okay?!
*jumble of words at the beginning*  There's clearly something wrong-
You don't know how to criticize a movie.
Felix.
That's why you don't
**BRP**
*imitating haters*Stick to your meme reviews, Felix
You don't like Star Wars
So I keep watching, okay, maybe *sad pewds*
!? It was one bad joke.. *PewDiePie noises*
It doesn't matter! *pained chuckle*
I love Star Wars!
Then, another joke hits you.
*ANOTHER SEIZURE*
*noises* Oh god, what was that? Was that even a joke?
What the he- *SEIZURE*
Ah! Another joke! Ah, God damn it. *laughter*
You know- a movie has bad humor if I'm the one criticizing it.
For bad humor.
movie review
It felt like the Lele Pons of comedy.
Just uh, people getting hurt and you're expected to go Hah! That's funny!
*1 LIKE = 1 PRAYER* PLEASE DONATE
He got hurt. He fell! (i hope he died)
That's hilarious! (exaggerated laugh.)
I see so many people defending this movie online
des-
despite the 94%...
critic review
How how HOW does this movie have 94%
how?
dont get me wrong, it wasn't bad..
but 94%?
Jesus christ
So many people wanna like this film so badly
and seeing people's reaction to-
eh
to it, an-and defending it
is-is hilarious to me.
I found this tweet, uhh and I seen a lot of people say the same thing
Man, a second viewing of the LAST JEDI really did the trick.
Turned me from a like to a lover.
Pewds: I love the movie now!
But really, once you've seen the movie 6 time, that's-
that's when it starts to get good. ok?
*GIGGLES*
I've seen reviewers not wanting to.. give the movie a rating right away because,
they want to like it so badly.
They want to make sure.. that they like it
*pops collar*
what movie will you eugh- give that sort of criticism to?
What mo-
H-how do you not show incredible bias, by-by admitting to that?
Like *ZOOMS IN* how- how are you a reviewer if- if you need to watch it twice to give it a review. *ZOOMS OUT*
I've seen some people deflecting saying
Dumb person: "Okay, well if you didn't like Star Wars (the last jedi) that means you hate Social Justice"
And I, yes.. tha- that's true I do.
But I didn't mind it in thi- in this film, I thought it was alright
I d- It- it didn't take away from anything I didn't care
It was nice to see a strong female lead
It was nice to see a mo- more diverse cast, even though i hate forced diverse casting
I thought it was alright!
I see so many people doing what I like to call "Twitter Rick & Morty Deflecting"
Where someone or something is facing criticism
And it's all just thrown away by nitpicking one of the
Many valid criticisms it's getting and just reducing that down
to some sort of lower IQ
Its as the cast said: Rian treats the audience as if hey are intelligent and can work things out for themselves;...
...Some need to realise that the film cannot do everything for you.
*Intelligent Pewds* To be fair you need extremely high level of IQ *breathes in* to understand Star Wars (the last jedi)
When the Porgs hits the windshield of the Millennium Falcon
That is saying something deeper about life
*has an existential crisis*
If you didn't like Star Wars (the last jedi) that's because you- you don't like Social Justice
If you don't like Star Wars (the last jedi) that's cause you- you're a fanboy
*ZOOMS* It's like, *ZOOMS IN MORE* no.
None of these things applied
I just thought it wasn't *Felix's mating call*
to put it simple, I didn't like the film because the characters felt holo
The movie completely ignored common sense to further the plot in a way I think
ehd
The most forgiving fan would still cringe enternally
in disbelief
The comedy was so out of place it felt like I was watching Avengers
And
I think switching directors mid-through in a trilogy had the effect of all the setup from the previous film
Being completely thrown out the window
Now
I didn't dislike everything about the film
I thought the CGI was really cool there was some scenes that were just mindblowingly
Amazing to look at I was like
"Wow, hey Marzia, that's pretty cool isn't it?"
I really like Kylo Ren and Ray's character
And I think the movie would've been a lot better if they just focused on them
*laughs*
But let's get into all the bad stuff.
First of all, the comedy.
My god, *not just yours*
**pewds laughs at my supreme joke**
The movie started with General Hux which, in the first film was a very serious character he was
he was almost like the reincarnation of Hitler
All of a sudden being in this movie (the last jedi) in the very first scene
Comic Relief
It didn't make any sense at all and as a viewer you were completely taken out of the film
There was this weird prank call with a pilot trying to- trying to distract him
It felt like I was watching Austin Powers
Or some- some Saturday Night Live skit
Of a parody of Star Wars
Fine, you know what if you wanna make that joke, fine.
But
*Pewds weighing an apple*
Changing a character's personality completely for the same of a joke
Why- Why? Why? *sad pewds*
Uhh..
Then there's the Porgs, those cute little penguin things
I like them!
I thought they were alright.
I- I knew people were gonna hate them but-
*shrugs a tiny*
They were funny
They were cute, and I like 'em
And I will buy FIVE of their
*thinks*
*changes mind*
Six of them
All of them!
I will buy all of them *in the world??*
There was one bit with the Porgs where Chewbacca is in the Millennium Falcon
And the Porgs are in his-- Cock Pit
And one of them is wearing this, like, headset thing
It looks like he's wearing a VR headset
And,
It was very cute, him doing that,
and it was very funny him doing that.
But.
It didn't make any sense, him doing that.
"Awkward silence"
"Awkward silence [Intensifes]"